what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar to talk about the latest
developments in the black clover story
we got some crazy twists and turns in
this one so make sure to stay tuned for
that
if you enjoy seeing these black clover
chapter reviews and want to keep them
coming the best you can do is show some
love for black clover by smashing that
like button and sharing this video let's
see if we can get 4000 likes on this one
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this crucial ring dye notification bell
or you will miss future black lower
chapter reviews keep in mind there will
be spoilers in this video we are talking
about the latest chapter chapter 253
after all now without further ado let's
jump into it we start where we left off
last chapter with Noelle's new epic form
this chapter is called bloodshed but the
million dollar question is who will be
losing the blood just the evil demon
lady or our justice and revenge seeking
mage ladies to whatever happens we're
told from the beginning that we'll get
some serious action in this one Noelle's
water bending has definitely reached new
heights
she stabbed Bonica with her water lands
but Monica only smiles her evil demonic
smile clearly not worried by the new
upgrade she's seen although we gotta
love the mermaid theme of this powerup
it makes a lot of sense and I like the
way Tabata handle to the design Bonica
is clearly messed up like those Opie
villains who get excited when someone
actually puts up a challenge because
they're so used to wrecking everyone
that they are forever bored seeing
someone that can actually get some hits
in on them raises the possibility of
escaping from that boredom which is
exciting
Noelle seems worried by this reaction
after what should have been a moment
where epic music played and a new power
of rec and overconfident enemy we end up
with the enemy telling Noelle not to die
too fast imagine giving it your best
shot
using your trump card teaming up with a
princess and the spirit of water
becoming a freakin mermaid or a merman
if you're Zoolander and after all that
your opponent just laughed and politely
asks you not to die too fast that's
clearly not a fun position to be a
Vanegas tarts increasing her demon
percentage increasing her power and
magic in the process keep in mind
because of princess lo-lo's water spell
vana cos blood magic is significantly
weakened and has trouble solidifying but
our princess
is still shocked by how much power
Bonica can still muster it's also
pointed out that ordinary attacks really
won't be enough to defeat Monica and I
feel like that's an understatement
we need to bring out the biggest of the
big guns in this kind of situation last
chapter Noelle's sea dragons roar spell
the one that shocked everyone when she
initially used it did nothing to vodka
what we need at this point is super Shan
Ron's roar to hurt this woman we see
Noel expertly maneuvering through the
water and an impressive speed it's great
to see how far she's come since back in
the day when she couldn't even control
her water magic we get another view of
Noel where tabatha is clearly showcasing
her new mermaid form and I'd love to see
how she even has water bracelets and
stuff in this form Noel is clearly in
her domain
she can't hope for better conditions
than this for her magic type but Bonica
just keeps on laughing like a madwoman
the whole time unfazed these mages with
demon powers all seem pretty messed up
people complained that hasta was crazy
and loud but he seems pretty normal
compared to these maniacs
Monica's like the Joker on steroids so
annoying that her eventual defeat is
going to be oh so sweet
for now though Bonica just keeps
powering up at 51% demon power just 1%
more than she was just that she's
drastically stronger no L can't help but
be surprised at her surging power level
Noel tries to sort of make Monica feel
guilty here saying that all Bonica cares
about is filling her own desires
however Monica just laughs and ups her
demon power to 52% now we get an
emphasis on the revenge aspect of this
battle Noel brings up how McGee Killa
killed her mother ICA silva someone that
even mateo leona had trouble beating
there's so much building up here for a
satisfying revenge story that I may have
to include it in my next installment of
my best revenge moments an anime we have
how annoying Monica is how powerful she
is how overconfident she is we got to
see a new upgrade from the well and we
have revenge for an Opie dead parent
thrown into the mix as well it's
checking off many epic revenge criteria
already and it isn't even over back to
the fight though Veronica just keeps on
increasing that demon percentage she up
set up to 53
sent and sends an attack at Noel that
looks devastatingly powerful what's
worse Monica says she doesn't even know
who ICA is she doesn't care about the
past she just wants to enjoy right now
the present moment I find it funny how
usually living in the present moment is
a good thing because people are usually
regretting the past or worrying about a
future problem that may never come but
here the evil crazy villain is spouting
off that philosophy it's interesting and
I still don't know what to make of that
but I suppose she takes it to a
dangerous extreme where she doesn't take
responsibility for any of her actions
and she throws morality out of the
window which is a huge no-no we then
jump - hasta fangirl number two mimosa
and her creepy simp of an opponent as
long as Veronica is alive this dude is
practically immortal and he'll just keep
trying to do weird things
mimosa looks like she's in a bind and
she's sweating from exhaustion but
interestingly enough she's still
confident she said that they trained to
beat people like gross tungsten then we
get a share thought between Noelle in
mimosa
revealing their motivations yes they
want to save the world and yes Noelle
wants to avenge her mother but there is
more to their motivation flashback time
engage and we see the three female
Musketeers talking our two clover
Kingdom girls are praising princess lolo
for making them stronger we got more
characterization for the princess she's
clearly talented so talented that Noel
says modesty looks like sarcasm on her
however the princess definitely has a
deep insecurity a kind of imposter
syndrome where she feels unworthy of
praise she tries to displace the credit
on the fact that her magic and grimoire
pulled the sum of what former Queens
accumulated but the water spirit is like
holed up you already had terrific power
to begin with and not everyone could
inherit those powers this princess is
like the insecure protagonist of some
other series like Shinji and to an
extent Deku in the beginning of MHA
while some characters start out pretty
confident like hasta and Luffy some
doubt whether they can really do what
others expect of that the princess is
this latter kind of character and she
wonders if someone as clumsy and dull as
her can really rule the Hart Kingdom but
remember that Auster's pretty dull in
his own way and Noel was clumsy enough
in the beat
but they still manage to grow and kick
butt by having the courage to not give
up we're all in the princesses both
sometimes wondering if we're imposters
and not good enough in university I
could get A's in my classes and still
feel like it's only a matter of time
before my professors figure out that I
don't know what I'm talking about but
then during my masters a very successful
professor that I looked up to said that
she also had imposter syndrome and that
blew my mind I learned that most people
have doubts about whether they're good
enough or not but the important thing is
being brave enough to try anyways that's
the only way you can get better and
don't wait until you're ready because
here's a secret you'll never feel ready
in Lolo's case she adds that she is
afraid of death as well she was afraid
of Annika when she fought her and then
Monica cursed her as a result she feels
like she's a failure as a queen then at
the risk of being an even bigger failure
she reveals that she's scared
and that she doesn't want to die she
cries completely showing her vulnerable
side it's a negative spiral though
because she feels guilty about crying
since in her words a princess Turin
crime public and shouldn't be worried
about herself but should worry about the
kingdom by the way keep in mind that
narrow a case wallow tale is here to on
the well shoulders and I think this is
an important scene for us to get we see
people like Julius Nova chrono who
seemed perfect
like they were born to rule they seem
like they have no fear and then we feel
guilty if we feel fear and think we
shouldn't but characters like the
princess remind us that it's normal to
have fear and we shouldn't feel guilty
about it
what's important is doing our best
anyways despite the fear courage is not
the absence of fear but acting in spite
of fear which is why I feel that
characters like o sob who feel
tremendous fear are in a way the bravest
Noel mmo's a comfort the princess and
tell her that of course she can cry
among friends and that permission to cry
means more to her princess than anything
else could just remember what mr. Miyagi
says in Karate Kid it's okay to lose to
the opponent but you must not lose to
fear this wise sensei is fully aware
that it's normal for humans to feel fear
and you can even cry if you need to the
important thing is just not to let the
fear stop you you act in spite of the
fear and whatever happens
so we come back to the present and we
now know about the secret conversation
and we know that no elements are
fighting for their friend and that's why
they're absolutely going to win and man
that's touching AF this is the power of
friendship done right
in the meantime vodka has gone to 65%
approaching her max of 70% real quick
before we know it she's at the full 70
percent and announces that she's coming
with all her power she looks like a
beast and if a 1% difference shocked
Noelle we can only imagine what another
19% difference on top of that is like
Lolo screams out for Noelle clearly
worried but BAM Noelle is not she thinks
to herself that that's what they've been
waiting for clearly this has all been
part of the plan we jump back to the
password a secret master plan to defeat
and overpowered enemy was revealed the
plan was to make Monica used up her
power and draw on all the demon power
she can use then they had a trump card
ready for her and that trump card was
narrow who remember was there when the
princess opened up so she's fighting for
her friend too she comes in with her
post time skipped south in epic fashion
and used the sealing magic eternal
prison to seal the demon power saying
she won't let scum like Monica take the
world or her friend and bam that's the
end of this epic goose bump inducing
chapter all along this was part of
Noelle's plan she was not necessarily
trying to beat Monica but was actually
trying to draw out her full power so
they could seal it and if this is it for
Magilla I'd be cool with that because
this came together beautifully but of
course we might see the enemy get an
upgrade too since they sometimes do that
as well either way if Noelle's revenge
is complete or if it will be completed
in a future chapter it is sweet and
satisfying a yes
the overconfident maniac got beat at
full power by characters who are scared
but did their best and came up with a
great strategy to stop a more powerful
opponent this is one of my favorite
chapters in a while and I look forward
to seeing how this ends and let me know
when you think we'll be seeing Austen
Yami again because as much as I do love
these girls I'm also eating to see my
black clover bros if you did enjoy this
chapter review and want to keep them
coming show black over some love by
smash
that like button let's see if we can get
4000 likes on this one if you haven't be
sure to subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification belt or you will
miss future black clover reviews lastly
the YouTube ad rates have significantly
dropped recently so the help and support
we're getting from our anime uproar
patrons is now more important than ever
a very special thank you goes out to our
patrons over on patreon who helped us
survive these YouTube issues and who
helped make videos like this one
possible first and foremost I want to
thank the legend acknowledged by Lord we
go himself
Efrain a and the one tier patrons the
ones who stand atop all clans Steven
grata a Lolo attend the world stealers
acquire respect potato
Jonathan King's sed Brandon Elias Papa
Smurf the school bus Emperor Taku and
Ritchie Martinez and our pro hero tier
patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson Kings
ljust Anatole Kazansky Angel Cruz
cricket XP Joel Stan that very Gucci
Alesha actor Jessica Calif on he no
commie and water
Bonnie parks Zoli art well worth two and
a hora Tian Fong cynical Kraken Volga 77
and deadly Saint thank you all so much
if you enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon comm
anime out Brook and becoming a patron
today for as little as one dollar if you
do so you'll get your name featured in
future videos alongside these amazing
people right here and you'll even get
access to our private patron only
discord where we talk about anime life
and of course dank memes so check out
patreon.com slash anime uproar link in
the description if you're interested you
can now join the YouTube challenge for
more content that way if you prefer
whichever way you choose to support us
you can get the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see you
space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]